[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
this
what's up everybody you tapped into the
group chat presented by fanduel live in
the bleach report
my name is kevin richards our betting
expert is kelly stewart
and if greg and i get on her bad side
she will trade us for lonzo ball
immediately and the ceo winners only
wednesdays
is greg ivory the only thing hotter than
the wall street bets subreddit right now
is chuck versus america each week we go
head-to-head
with the great charles barkley and you
guys the audience you pick the props
last week you voted that lebron james
would outscore giannis anta takumo
in their head-to-head matchup and you
were right
braun delivered 34 points to giannis's
25
so may we see the leaderboard we are
still undefeated america
6-0 against charles barkley he drops
to two and four and i gotta say this as
long as you're riding with us
g-money is riding for you
cabbie yes sir you know what i'm ready
to do
let me i see we got adam lefko in the
comments i gotta introduce adam levco
adam lefkow and everybody else that is
new to the show
this right here is called the handy
dandy ipad and this is what i'm gonna do
when i get on the handy dandy ipad i i
hand out
hoodies so back into the comments cavi
back into the comments
i got uh mill mlie
both 13 saying dame dolla never fails to
splash it's a lock
shouts out to you bro you walk away with
a hoodie i got
i got i got a dog asking how can he get
his shirt a dog i got you right here
check this out
i'm giving you a hoodie and our producer
is gonna hit you up
right after this show he's gonna dm you
and give you a hoodie a dog shouts out
to you
b royal one yo greg i need a hoodie for
arctic freeze here in new england
guess what brother i'm going to be
warming you up b-roy
we are warming you up cabbie i know
you're ready to cut me off yeah i'm zero
we're ready we're ready
salute to lefko my guy's always ahead of
the curve when it comes to trading so
you know tapping with levco after the
show but let's get into what we got
in tonight's show which is chuck versus
america early on social we asked you
today which one of these props should
we lock in steph curry or dame lillard
over four and a half three-pointers made
steph or dame to be cooking tonight over
four and a half three-pointers made
this is that we put out a twitter poll
overwhelming that you guys are
riding with steph curry leaning at 73
that might be the most lopsided twitter
poll we've had so far
on squad ride greg this is a super small
sample size
in the last three games steph curry has
averaged
five three-point shots made and damian
liller has ever
averaged four three-pointers made i know
it's a super small
sample size but what do you want the
audience to do
cabbie this is what i need the audience
to do
go into the comments look up a steph
curry gift
and entered it because we are writing
with steph nah
nah nah nah all right here i need what i
really need you guys to do is comment
steph
or dame tell me who we're riding with
tell me who we're riding with i think
you guys should ride with steph
obviously
but tell me who we're riding with kelly
the audience is gonna tell us who
they're riding with who are
you riding with you got your money on
dame you got your money on that
stepmother i see the plus
130 you talk value kelly come on
this is where it gets hard because i
wish you guys didn't show the poll
because now everybody's like oh kelly
just wants to fade us
that's not what i was gonna do actually
in rehearsal
i told cabbie look don't don't give away
family sick it's secrets cows no family
secrets
oh i won't tell them what i really said
that's for off air but anyway
all jokes aside i wish that poll wasn't
that lopsided because that's all
anybody's going to say now it's not even
fair
i had all this great analysis i got
pages of notes right here
on why i like dame but guess what it's
all good
i do like dame here and i think that is
because dame
is a one-man wrecking crew you know what
the portland trailblazers
win games when dame goes off i think
dame's gonna go off tonight
i understand no disrespect to steph
curry actually i think both of these
could probably go over
but since you're making me pick i'm
taking dame dolla plus 102.
and without your yusuf nurkic and
without
cj mccollum dame dollar basically has
the green light to shoot from
anywhere in the gym so he can put up
maybe 10 or 12
three-point shots tonight he's averaging
close to his career best
around 28 points per game i'm saying
lock in
uh logo lillard at same time always when
that guy steps in the gym
hey money how's the audience reacting to
this one
cabbie before i get into the audience
because it's a it's a complete landslide
in the comments
before i say but yeah before i get there
though
who started pulling up from anywhere in
the gym
who started that i mean clay thompson
you might
you you might be lazy you might have a
point g money
but who can do it more consistently
though g-money
who's known for pulling up at the logo
who can do it more can sit
really that's where you want to go
consistency
we're talking about steph curry here
we're we're talking about
cabbie actually i'm gonna just get into
the comments i'm gonna get into the
comments
i'm gonna get some stuff that's by
phoenix tonight and dame's got houston
which is playing pretty good defense but
double teams all around i mean he's
facing
he's facing chris paul we've we've seen
this it's a track record you can
literally google
steph curry chris paul and you'll see
chris paul
getting cooked just literally
cabbie but anyway i'm in the comments i
got to give away some hoodies i got to
give away somebody okay because they're
they're showing mad love to steph curry
i got slim
reaper he says steph curry mr
fundamentals
mr fundell meant mr fundamentals
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i got it
fundamentals
i got it uh mr curry man they're riding
with steph curry
i got laser 84 with the steph curry gif
you see it
yeah you see it i know you see it cabbie
he's going to be
watching but look at the one right above
that look at the one right above that
that's the whole point kathy i'm gonna
start getting in i'm gonna get my own
ipad
i'm gonna start jumping in the comments
because i feel like greg
really just cherry picks on what greg
really wants here
you can hop into the comments maybe we
get a third party here to like actually
monitor the comments make this a little
bit more fair
i don't know kelly you could you're more
than welcome to hop into the comments
whenever
you want whenever you want people's
riding with steph
uh cabbie i'm riding with steph hey when
when you said slim reaper i mean is
kevin durant tapped in
that might be pretty dope america make
sure you tap into the iconic
pre-game show inside the nba on tnt to
find out if charles barkley
is rocking with us and steph curry or if
he's fading america
and going with damian lillard and make
sure you get on fanduel
um to and bet the steph curry over four
and a half three-point shots
for tonight's game against phoenix and
don't forget to send us your videos to
be featured on your
on our show now let's talk three by two
we invented this prop because and it's
the best one in
the entire betting sphere and
even though we invented it and we got
off to a rock like a rocket ship start
like we were 6-0 at the gate we took an
l like anyone trying to get the new
sneaker drop on the sneaker app it's
impossible
and impossibly we took an l but we're
six and what
we're six and one america and the simple
question is will there be
two three-pointers made in the first
three minutes of the game
two three-pointers made in the first
three minutes of the game
tonight we're tapping in to the portland
trail blazers versus the houston rockets
at 7 30 p.m eastern that is the question
and um g-money do you anticipate
celebrating with mikey locks later
tonight if this hits
the 3x2 from the words
of the great bradley bill the other day
cabbie is the sky blue
of course of course i'm looking forward
to celebrating with mike
celebrating with my guy mikey locks and
a whole bunch of sunsets
i was gonna say i thought skye was
sunset colored whenever you were like
that's a good point okay
is it blue or orange that's the sunset
i mean the sky oh the i mean it's
whatever it's whatever the vibes are
it's whatever the vibes are filling that
day cabbie
but anyway yes yes yes yes i'm looking
forward
to uh to riding with my guy mikey locks
but i need everybody in the comments i
need
everybody in the comments tell me should
we ride
this 3x2 just say yes i need a lot of
yeses in the comments
but let me know if we should be riding
this 3x2 now kelly talk to us
talk to us talk to us do you think we
should be riding this three by two today
do you think we should be riding the yes
or do you think we should be thinking
about
the no so you guys always use funny
analogies and i don't think you guys
appreciate some of the little rednecks
that we have that follow the show
so i'm gonna use a country analogy here
for the day
and when you get bucked off a horse what
does your dad tell you to do you better
get your butt back on and that is
exactly what i am doing
today and don't act like we don't have
those kids i've seen the crossbows
and the crazy chickens and all the stuff
on the show there is those kids are
country okay
anyway that being said i'm getting back
on the horse here
if i get bucked off again though i might
have a broken ankle so
that being said cabbie mentioned it
already portland versus houston both
these teams
love to shoot from the arc both these
teams yes i understand houston is
playing a little bit better defense
but they love to go out firing i think
we see this hit tonight
i get my money back from last week if
you're putting kelly's riding let's go
she is right if you're putting crossbows
with chickens in the comments
we're all family we all ride together
but i'm gonna
i'm i'm about to bring some bad vibes to
the chat like
uh robin hood or wall street like in the
last five games
uh the blazers and the rockets have only
hit the three by two twice
so i'm just going with the it's a little
bit of a recency bias
but i'm leaning no i know boogie cousins
has range so does j
sean tate and obviously damian lillard
and
robert covington but i'm leaning no this
week
specifically for the three by two in
portland and houston
the my i apologize for the bad vibes
i apologize guys yeah cabbie cabbie
cabbie yeah
yeah my thing is you guys just said dame
lillard's gonna have a day right you
guys just said he's gonna have more than
what is it
four and a half three pointers yeah why
can't we get
two in the first three minutes yeah
cabbie why can't we think that way let's
see
a little optimistic here a little
optimistic
that is more vibey you're right
it's it's it's okay kevin it's okay i'm
in the comments and um
they're booing you cabbie they're
they're booing you in the comments it is
okay
it is okay we in the comments
i'm used to it you can take some of the
heat today
i'm just spinning facts the comments
cabbie they're they're going so fast
it was full of yeses it was full of
yeses they are writing and i'm writing
i see a a floor full of shooters we got
dame lillard on the floor
we got oladipo we got john wall
if they play uh i mean
four foot of shooters i'm taking my
chances with the yes and i'm gonna have
the vibes going sunsets in the comments
knee sunsets in the comments right now
need sunsets in the comments
i'm gonna have the vibes going with
mikey locks so we're rocking with the
s check out our br socials for the link
to the 3x2
odds on fanduel lock-in it's the most
fun bet
in any sport the 3x2 and as always
send us your videos if it hits and if
you're vibing
after winning 10 straight games on the
road for the lakers
lebron james has now surpassed luka
doncic
as the odds-on favorite to win nba mvp
in year 18. you know this man has been
on fire recently
so let's take a look back at brian's
recent performance
who's doing the locking both of them
locked up together as lebron shoots a
deep three whoa
ten lebron james closing in on a
triple-double kuzma
can't finish but lebron over the top
that he is young now defending with
williams the shade but there's lebron
down the lane three on the shot clock
james with the long three and knocks it
down
to fight back to lebron he's got a hurry
long distance three got it
wow head here by schroeder
and lebron james my my guy is on a
it's like a pissed off lebron like we
saw pissed off aaron charles rogers
cook the nfl we're seeing a pissed off
lebron james let's take a look at the
current mvp at
odds as offered by fanduel we'll see lbj
at the top at plus 350
joel embiid at plus 600 he's moved up
there's luca doncic before the season he
was plus 390.
he's now 650 nicola yokic 650
kevin durant the current mvp giannis
antetokounmpo
is plus 1200 the two-time mvp steph
curry is plus 1200
we go down the list anthony davis plus
2100
kawhi leonard is interesting too this is
this is a strong board
earlier in the week the odds were five
to one on fanduel that lebron would win
nba mvp and somebody put 20 000
with a which would give the person a
potential payout
of a hundred and eight thousand if
lebron
wins nba mvp that is just
crazy 20 bans on a future bet
hey if it hits that person we're
celebrating actually gmoney is that
person in the comments right now because
i'd like to have a word
with that that that individual uh in the
dms
cabbie that person might or might not be
in the comments but i'm over here struck
it's just struck that lebron is the
favorite to win
right now i'm struck i'm struck i'm
struck because i think
it's gonna be kevin durant and i need
the audience to do me a favor
i need the audience to do me a favor is
it cap
or no cap that lebron is favorited
above a.d to win mvp this year is that
cap or no cap i need you guys to talk
about
kd above kevin durant yes kd
kd yes above kd because kathy
you think lebron's the best in the
league i think
kd's the best in the league so we got to
settle this i need the audience to tell
me
and i'm i'm looking at it cabbie i see a
lot of kevin durant mvps in the comments
right now
i'm looking at it so lebron being first
it might be cap but uh kelly
kelly kelly please give us your take
cause i know you coming with some value
always greg look i don't dislike your
kevin durant
plus 750 i know that hardin and kyrie
are going to play a big role there and i
think with mvp
like cabbie said you have to literally
be a standout player again
no disrespect kevin durant i think he's
excellent and yes i think he's the best
player on that team
i think the nets need another year i
just don't see it
this year i'm shocked that luca has
fallen so far from grace i know that
the mavs have not played as well as they
did in the bubble but i do think that we
will see him
start to come back up so right now i
think there's some value on luca save
your money on lebron
we all know that he's going to be the
greatest of all time he's not yet
still jordan but he will be the greatest
of all time before he retires that's
not up for discussion there's just not a
lot of value at plus 350 right now and
the books
only moved off of that because of a
large bet maybe they respected the guy
maybe they didn't but they're trying to
hold their position here i think lucas
still holds a tremendous amount of value
because again you are the most valuable
player to your team
when you have too many other people on
your team you can't be it
right now a.d struggling lebron looks
great when ad
gets in mid-season form i think we'll
see lebron take a step back
if i had 20 grand to bet on the nba mvp
i would sprinkle around i don't have 20
ground but i did do some sprinkling
because i just got so enamored with this
prop bet and when i saw
braun move i was like i need to jump on
this so this is
totally uncharacteristic for me and
maybe mikey locks was in the back of my
head a little bit
but i went to the sports book i have a
future on lebron james i have a future
on
joel embiid i have a future on steph
curry and i have a future on
kevin durant and nicola jokic on my
phone i
i don't know i i'm volume shooting with
the nba envy make money that way
but the but the odds are so like steph
is plus 1200 yokitches plus i think
i got him at plus 1300 kd plus a
thousand
you know before the hardin trade right
but lebron wins you're
you're gonna lose money we gotta think
positively okay
i might mikey locks with mikey lots to
tell you to stop bringing bad vibes
and you gotta be vivi so i have five
futures
right now and uh i don't know which way
obviously it's gonna it's gonna go the
voters are gonna go but
each like so many players on this board
have compelling narratives
the nba media loves narratives they love
first-time mvps
you know braun could win his fifth i'm
just all over the place i don't know
g money which name have you seen most
often in the in the comments
for nba mvp this year
handy dandy i'm in
in the handy dandy notebook uh ipad i'm
not the notebook but the ipad
looking for uh some takes cabbie and i
see i see a lot of lebron shouts out to
tg
laub tglaub23 you're walking away with a
hoodie
uh they're saying a lot of no cap i see
a lot of
cap i got ben e h-u-p-l-l
he says no cap i got james harden is in
the mix james harden
is in the mix uh cabbie the comments is
all over the place to be honest
i see a lot of lebron see a lot of kd
see a lot of caps see a lot of no cap
uh it's hard to track this but i mean
i'm just happy that they're engaging oh
i also see a lot of joker
a lot of the joker i see a lot of the
joker yeah they're putting a lot of
gifts up of the joker shout out to
everybody i said if i mentioned your
name
you're walking away with a hoodie uh
cabbie it might be time to
move on joker is averaging a triple
double i think the reason i sprinkled on
joker is because kelly
planted that seed in the back of my
mouth back uh last year during the
bubble and he played exceptional he's
continuing to do that
uh this year all right it's our favorite
time of the show
this is where kelly and i get to make
fun of our little brother greg ivory as
he endeavors
to hit a single game five-legged parlay
these are very hard all right and
there's money on the line there's a 500
bet that greg will not hit one of these
five leg
single game parlays in the entire nba
season so that means that each week
kelly and i can make fun of greg because
as we take a look at last week's ticket
g-money look at it was not successful
three for two okay three four five me
three for five three five tipper five is
not bad
deeper five's not bad i mean it's not
five for five gabby my favorite was
brandon ingram i don't think he got a
single rebound in that game
refreshing the screen to see and i was
like oh this is going to be great he's
just not even going to try to get a
rebound
he may have gotten one alright g money
it's your time this week shoot your shot
my friend
build that parlay cabbie kelly
it is time it is time we are riding the
golden state warriors and the golden
state warriors
only with this single game parlay
throwing a little curve ball at you guys
all right here we go starting it off
starting it off we got andrew wiggins
over 17 and a half points i do see my
guy andrew wiggins having a good game
today
not only just scoring but cabbie i'm to
take it over to the rebounding aspect of
the game
and i'm going to go andrew wiggins over
four and a half rebounds i see my guy
having
a lot of all-star cabbie the all-stars
the all-star game is coming up my guy is
trying to make a team not saying he's
gonna make it i'm saying my guy is
trying to make a team and he's been
he's been uh he's been improving over
this year he's been uh
he's been doing his thing so moving on
moving on cabbie
i gotta talk about that batman the
babyface assassin
one half of the splash brothers steph
curry
his over under is sitting at 28.5 points
he's facing chris paul tonight
and like i said earlier in the show all
you got to do is
google steph curry chris paul
and you'll see a bunch of highlights of
a bunch of cooking up by steph
so i'm rocking with steph going over
over
28 and a half points shout out to my guy
steph i need you to come through for us
this is an optimistic ticket already bro
okay keep going
let me keep going here we go we got
draymond green draymond draymond
draymond
i need draymond to have one of his games
i need draymond just to have a draymond
game i got draymond sitting that over
under
five and a half assists that means
draymond go grab six
and i think he can we're gonna rock with
over
five and a half rebounds with my guy
draymond green
uh lock that one in let's go draymond
you got anything to say about that yeah
don't don't forget james wiseman the
young buck is going to eat up a lot of
those rebounds too and then
he's playing against deandre ayton bro
in the paint a seven-footer who wouldn't
have he's like averaging a double double
start having a cycle before each
a half every game is gonna be a half he
picks half over under so it's either he
has zero or he has one because he never
ever ever takes an under
i'm gonna set the other half moving on
moving on to the last one moving on to
the last one
here we go we got kelly ubrey facing his
former team today guys
kelly ubrey is facing his former team
and do you guys not think he's going to
show up cabbie i see you have your hands
on your face
do you not think kelly uber is going to
show up okay wait what's the prop though
it better
what is the prop better not be three
pointers
it probably is if it is it better be
under he's sitting at 14 and a half
points
i think he's gonna go over he's about to
get traded
the rumors are about to get traded to
the pelicans he's at cabbie
he did an interview yesterday he doesn't
care about that he just cares about
winning if you go look it up
he said he doesn't care he just wants to
win with that being said
do you want to win this ticket in ball
greg do you want to win
great question kathy
yeah of course this is a solid ticket
this is a solid solid
ticket i'm ready to two and three we can
pull up the ticket pull up the ticket
there's the ticket right there you guys
see it we go turn that fifty dollars to
almost a band ski we gotta turn into a
little cool little nine honey
a little cool little 900 but i like i
like this parlay right here it's all
golden state warriors by the way
so yeah golden state is an underdog on
the road
by the way i'm on the sun's minus one
and a half but in all jokes aside
the golden state warriors are gonna go
dominate on the road
do i think they're going to dominate no
i don't think they're going to dominate
i think that part of laser says that
they're going to dominate
our ball game no kelly
they can have a high scoring game
without dominating the game
the parlay says that the warriors are
going to score points but that doesn't
mean that they're going to dominate the
game
you said dominate high scoring versus
dominate is two totally different things
well listen good luck man i know the
warriors have won three in a row but
good luck uh kelly i'm gonna tell you on
that sun's one and a half
just so that we can make fun of our
little brother greg ivory thank you for
joining us on the squad ride presented
by fanduel
remember these three things that we
taught you it might be too late
to get value on a future bet for lebron
to win mvp
but there's still some elite players on
that list
america we always ride together against
chuck
and we're dominating right now and
lastly it's always fun to make fun of
your friends
and their single games nothing but love
greg nothing but love
when you got money on it alongside kelly
stewart and greg ivory we are leaving
the group chat
thank you so much peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you